はい。とゆうわけで
今回、SPINNSさんと私はじめしゃちょーの、コラボ商品が発売されまーす！
はい、とゆうわけで今回SPINNSさんから発売されるのは
こちらのフード付きの白衣と
この、見覚えがるのではないでしょうか、所沢の見た目をした
小さなスライムカラーのぬいぐるみが、発売されます。
はい、こちらの白衣。パーカーみたいにフードが付いております。
これ取り外しが可能になってて、付けてもいいし、つけなくてもオッケーです。
完全に、パっと見白衣なんですけども
このポケットのほうにスライムの、模様が入ったりしています。
フードとかも付いているので普通に外でも着れそうな感じでございます。
そしてもうひとつ、こちらのぬいぐるみ
所沢ちゃんの親戚です。
こっちのキーホルダーが伸びるようになってまして、かばんとかにも付けれるようになっています。
顔がそっくりでしょ。
はじめしゃちょーのH Sと書いてあります。
それで、これ白衣パーカーのここにですね
ぴったり入るので
いつも一緒にお出かけができます。
ハイ、こんな感じです。
ね？
この子、背中が定期入れになっているので
こちらに定期とかを入れて、これをかばんにつけることもできます。
こちらのパーカーとスライムカラーの所沢
7月中旬ごろからSPINNSさんで販売されるので
皆さん是非チェックしてみてください
じゃあな！